[Music]
hey you guys so we're doing another book
review today
so not too long ago a couple weeks back
uh i got an email from a
pennsylvania-based author and poet named
oliver c seneca
and in this email he asked if i would
like to receive a an ebook copy of his
latest novel which is called faces in a
window
for me to review
so of course i was like uh hey free [ __ ]
i'm all over that so i was like yeah
send it to me and he's like no rush you
don't have to you know you can you can
wait i know you know you have other
things to review and stuff but i you
know if somebody sends me a book i
usually like to review it as quickly as
possible so as soon as i was done with
the the couple that i had already
started then i uh got into this one
so this book faces in a window uh was
published by sunbury press in late march
of 2022 so it's very very recent so i
will not spoil anything about it because
it's only been out for a month month and
a half something like that
this is actually his second novel uh his
first one was called when the sky goes
dark and that came out back in 2019 i
went to his website and read the
description of that one that one sounds
kind of more like an apocalyptic uh type
of thing like there's a big brawl like
on a campus and a bunch of people die
and then
kind of just it seemed kind of like you
know maybe this isn't what it is but it
seemed like kind of like a rage virus
type situation which sounded good but
like i said like apocalyptic but this
one that he sent me faces in a window is
a lot more
kind of an intimate ghost story haunted
house or actually haunted school type
situation and i'm kind of more into that
than i am apocalyptic stories although
the apocalyptic one sounded uh pretty
good as well
now i will say from the start that um
this is a pretty solid well-written
novel uh has some kind of cool like
spooky imagery reminded me a little bit
if you've seen the movie um we are still
here with barbara crampton and i think
larry fessenden is in it uh when did
that come out 2015 2016 something like
that but this kind of gave me a little
bit of that sort of vibe although that's
kind of more
over the top and gory and stuff but i
don't know some of the imagery and that
like reminded me of this
uh this also has
a little bit of like a sort of
old-fashioned
autumn in new england type of vibe
almost sort of like i want to say like
the lady in white or something like that
um and i like that type of stuff uh but
there were some issues i had with it and
i'll kind of get into that later on
because i was having like a hard time
like articulating what they were i did
enjoy this overall but um i'll try and
see if i can sort out kind of how i felt
about it later on
so uh the story gets out to a pretty uh
rousing start uh you know and you get
like interested in it right away
so in the very first scene you have this
elderly man and he's pretty much like
driving like a bat out of hell away from
a school where he had been teaching
this is only like a page or two
into it and so
somewhere along the way there's a
reference to another teacher at the same
school who
recently died of some aggressive form of
cancer
and then uh the old man who's driving
and he's kind of like thinking to
himself and his thoughts are racing and
stuff and then he looks in his rear-view
mirror and he sees a vision of like all
these charred looking people back there
and uh at that point he like plows into
a tree or a phone pole or something like
that and goes flying through the
windshield and he dies so like i said
this is like the first two pages so i
was like okay you got my attention
so after this prologue uh then we're
introduced to our two main protagonists
and these are really the two characters
there are a lot of characters but these
are really the only two that you spend a
significant amount of time with
one of these characters is ian evans
who's kind of this
sort of laid-back uh history teacher
he's like a younger guy like in his 20s
you know late 20s
uh he's just taken his first full-time
teaching position at a catholic middle
school called saint stephens and it's in
a really small town in delaware
now when we're first introduced to ian
like in the first chapter after the
prologue where the old guy dies in the
car crash
uh ian is having this really really
horrible nightmare
uh in which he's sort of like racing
through the hallways of this school and
it's kind of like burning and like
falling in around him like the floors is
falling in and the ceilings are falling
in and he keeps seeing like these creepy
figures like in the smoke and he's like
hearing somebody call for help and
there's like you know other creepy
imagery that i won't really spoil
so he wakes up from this nightmare
and uh it's actually the first day of
school like his alarm is going off and
he has to get ready to go
so he figures oh well you know i'm just
nervous about this being my first
full-time teaching job and it's the
first day and blah blah so i'm just you
know anxious about that so that's why
i'm having nightmares
so they kind of established there's a
little bit as you go as the story goes
on you learn a little bit more about
ian's character um he actually really he
didn't he says he didn't really like
school uh when he was growing up but he
wanted to be the kind of teacher that
would have gotten him more interested in
school so he's very very into teaching
he doesn't really care about making a
[ __ ] ton of money he just wants to at
least inspire a few people and make
school interesting for them because he
knows how hard school can be
uh so he's just taken this job this
middle school sort of he's not really
like um oh i don't want to work here for
you know anything like that but he's
just kind of like oh i'm taking this for
now like to get some experience because
he has you know he's subbed and things
but
this is his first full-time one and he's
like but eventually i'd like to go back
to college and get my master's in uh
with a view to teaching at the college
level so that's what he would want to do
so then our second main character is a
uh young woman a she's
very pretty very attractive but she's
also kind of like anxiety like has some
anxiety issues and her name is michelle
thompson
now she has actually taken a job at the
same school and she's going to be
teaching religion
now she's uh seems to be at something of
a crossroads in her life uh she's had to
move in with her aunt and uncle i guess
it was like some kind of relationship
that broke up or whatever and she's
moved in with her aunt and uncle in this
little town in delaware until she can
kind of get this job going get on her
feet and then you know eventually she
kind of wants to move on get married do
that kind of stuff too later on this i
think is this is also her first
full-time teaching position
so it turns out as we kind of go along
the narrative that these two teachers
were hired at the same time
at st stephens middle school
because uh two of the beloved teachers
uh that they are replacing
both died over the summer
one of them from cancer and one of them
in a car crash so now you know what that
prologue was referring to
now both of these teachers apparently
were very well loved by both students
and staff so
ian and michelle are really worried that
they're not going to be able to
you know live up to the reputations of
their predecessors i guess
but as it turns out uh neither of them
have too much to worry about in that
regard i mean they have some other
things to worry about this is a horror
novel after all but uh yeah but as far
as like their teaching prowess goes they
don't really have to worry about that uh
the students both love them
uh love both of them and the rest of the
faculty are like really friendly not i
was gonna say like
aggressively friendly not like the
rosemary's babies the cast of bets like
the neighbors friendly not like that but
just like so friendly you know how some
people are just like so nice and so
friendly and stuff like that that almost
like makes you
nervous because you're like what the
[ __ ] what do you want from me like
what's your deal um it's kind of like
that like they're all really nice but
you know not like i said not in a cast
event sort of way but just enough that
it's a little bit unnerving
another thing that both ian and michelle
who are as i said both in their like mid
to late 20s i think they're 27 something
like that another thing that they find a
little bit strange is that every uh
single other teacher and every other
member of the staff is old as [ __ ] like
not not like vampire old but they're all
like you know 70s 80s some of them even
a little bit older than that so they're
all like [ __ ] ancient right so they
think that's a little bit weird but then
they're like well maybe that's good
because you know maybe this is such a
great job that you know people don't
want to leave and they just want to like
teach you forever so like so that's you
know that's promising right
now they do actually both of them
end up befriending one particular member
like i said everybody's really nice
nobody's mean to them or anything like
that but they do actually uh
specifically make friends with this one
guy who's like a janitor there and his
name is rick
and uh he's also quite old and has been
at the school for a really long time
uh but he's like a really really nice
dude and he's kind of the guy that
knows a [ __ ] ton about the mysterious
past of this saint stephen's middle
school which uh you know we'll figure
out as the story goes on
so as the book progresses uh the
chapters sort of like alternate back and
forth
from ian's perspective to michelle so
like i said you have to prologue with
the old guy
you know hitting the tree at the
beginning and then it goes like ian
michelle and michelle ian michelle and
it just does that pretty much uh
throughout the entire book i don't think
there's any deviation from that so the
two of them because they're the only
young people
in the school full of old farts uh they
start developing a romance sort of even
though it's actually kind of chaste
which i'll get into in a little bit
but uh independently of each other they
also start experiencing these really
weird
and really scary like paranormal
occurrences at the school like ian in
particular uh start seeing like he'll be
looking around his classroom and there's
like an empty desk where a student
didn't show up and then he'll kind of
think that he sees like a sort of a
blackened
uh figure like a shadow figure
sitting in the seat and then he blinks
and it's gone he has like a lot of
nightmares again about the school
burning down or about seeing like all
these kind of blackened uh figures like
shadow type figures burned figures so he
sees that and then
michelle
uh she specifically sees this nun who is
clearly not alive although she doesn't
really look ghostly necessarily but she
kind of looks like i don't know she says
she looks kind of like gray and she like
moves really fast so i don't even know
if like michelle thinks she's a ghost at
first she just kind of sees her and
she's like why is that [ __ ] like
glaring at me like that and just just
trying to like figure out who it is but
then she asks about it and they turn it
turns out that it's somebody named
sister harriet and she is actually dead
so she did that so she keeps seeing that
and then as i said they're both having
nightmares separately also usually about
you know uh some burning or like these
black figures like these burned looking
figures
and then they also have it kind of gets
worse and worse and then they also have
these nightmares about their own deaths
like seeing their own funerals or you
know things like that which is very
upsetting obviously
now one thing though is that both of
them even though they're experiencing
all this [ __ ] up [ __ ] and are both
getting like really stressed out like
they can't sleep and they can't you know
they're they keep seeing things like a
lot of times they'll see things like
while they're at school and it like wigs
them out and [ __ ] but the thing about it
is that they don't like tell each other
even though they've sort of started like
i said doing like a little bit of a
chaste romance sort of thing where it's
like let's going out for little coffee
dates and talking about their lives and
stuff but
it seems like both of them like neither
one of them really wants to kind of like
pop that cherry where it's just kind of
like hey are you saying ghosts and [ __ ]
in the school because i sure am you know
what i mean so it just kind of seems
like they probably would have talked
about that sooner but it takes like more
it's almost like halfway through the
book before they actually like confess
to one another hey i've been saying this
really weird [ __ ] and they're like hey
me too like weep as we yeah and then
they gotta like kind of figure out what
to do
so as i said now this book is quite new
like i said it's only been out for like
a month and a half as of this recording
so i don't really want to spoil any more
about it
but this was pretty solid book it was
pretty uh entertaining
but i will say that there and this is
like i said it's kind of hard for me to
like put my finger on there was
something kind of tonally about this one
that sort of
didn't really resonate with me or kind
of kept
me at arm's length i guess if you want
to say that and as i said i'm having a
hard time like articulating what it
could be although
okay
let me see if i can try and
paint a picture for you
for one thing i kind of got the distinct
impression
that this story was supposed to be
taking place in like the 50s or the 60s
but it's not it's actually set in the
present day so i'm not really sure if
you're getting what i'm getting at
the characters in it like not the old
people but um ian and michelle like both
of them like they would swear and stuff
like if scary [ __ ] happened they'd be
like oh [ __ ] or something like that and
they made references to like modern
things like modern pop music and [ __ ]
like that
but the way that it was done
sounded like
it sounded like somebody who
was really really sheltered or didn't
really know about
those things like talking about it is
that weird and it's just and the author
is like a young guy so i was just kind
of like i don't know it was just like
really really strange so a lot of the
books sounded a little bit prim
or prissy i think that was the first
word that kind of came to mind it
sounded like prissy that's not exactly
right but maybe prim is better because i
think prissy sounds too mean and that's
it's not it's not like that it's just
i don't know it just sounded very like
somebody that was like really sheltered
had written it or or was trying to get
across that these characters were very
sheltered because that's kind of how the
characters came across
now i realize that
the story is taking place and like i
said it could be just this one because i
haven't read um oliver senorka's other
book which is kind of more like an
apocalyptic type story so it might
totally be different and maybe he was
just going for that tone for this
particular thing because this book is
set in a catholic school and pretty much
all the characters other than ian and
michelle are old as [ __ ] uh so and are
old-fashioned so you know they're very
uh formal you know as you know i prefer
to be called mr whatever and they're not
like [ __ ] or anything like they're
not you know super stern or conservative
or anything they're all like really
really friendly
but they're very
old-fashioned you know what i mean
they're very old-fashioned they're very
formal in their ways and as i said
that's not too surprising for the old
characters because i know like a lot of
old people are kind of genteel like that
maybe genteel is a good word but ian
michelle ian and michelle are supposed
to be in their 20s and they kind of act
like that too which i thought was a
little bit weird because look it's hard
for me to say because i was not raised
religiously i don't really know any
people that are particularly i don't
hang out or know any people that are
particularly religious
so maybe this is
something maybe this is some kind of
like uh you know just a cultural
difference i guess if you want to say it
like that whereas just like people that
go to catholic school or that or live in
these really small like new england type
towns that are all kind of like uh you
know based around this little kind of
like let's do the little oktoberfest
festival and let's do and everything's
just very wholesome and stuff and it's
like i guess i didn't really grow up
like that so it's just really hard for
me to relate to so to me it seemed
almost as though like had this story
took been taking place in like the 50s i
would have been like oh okay i gotcha
you know what i mean but because it was
the modern day it just seemed a little
bit strange it just seemed a little bit
jarring that's all but yeah so everybody
just sounds like really sheltered like
for example like ian and michelle who
as i said they're kind of like the only
young people here but they have they
also have like a lot in common and stuff
and
they're kind of like dating or them
start dating it almost struck me as you
know in mystery science theater how they
do some of those like dating like psas
like the dating like short films and
stuff that they made for schools
schools and colleges like in the 50s it
kind of reminded me of that a little bit
i don't know it's just there's just
something like really really weird about
it and like i said maybe that's why i
don't know this is my heathen ass i
don't maybe that's what it is it's like
like just the tone of it was very
strange and like kind of like
old-fashioned as though it was set a
long time ago even though it's the
modern day
and i kind of feel like the dialogue had
a little bit of that too there was like
it was it was very prudish it seemed a
little bit prudish
even though as i said the characters
swore and stuff like that but everybody
just seemed like even the young
characters seemed very old-fashioned
like you know i'm just looking for a man
to marry and like someone with faith and
blah blah which you know that's fine if
that's what you're doing it just you
know i don't hang out with people like
that so it didn't really um
so to me it just seemed like
like really like old people stuff i will
say too that a lot of the dialogue
seemed kind of not pointless necessarily
but it seems kind of like it seems very
like an aw shucks kind of
uh tone to it and
a lot of the conversations that they had
didn't really play into the larger
narrative to any great degree and i kind
of got the feeling that well he's trying
to like give them like quirks and like
do like characterization and stuff but i
don't know
i'm not entirely sure like how
successful that was because okay so the
way the story is laid out like i said it
goes back and forth from like ian's
point of view to michelle's point of
view and just like switches back and
forth between them so the so the scenes
will be like you know it's you know the
scenes the first day of school from
ian's point of view and then the first
day of school from michelle's point of
view and like the creepy [ __ ] they saw
that day and then there's like other
significant school events like carnivals
or midterms or whatever and then there's
like you know scenes where ian and
michelle are like going on a coffee date
or they're talking to rick like about
some creepy [ __ ] or like the you know
the history of the school or whatever
like the terrible [ __ ] that happened
back in the old days and that kind of
stuff and the whole thing like leads up
the whole thing takes place like right
prior to christmas like it ends like
right before christmas and then we jump
ahead a few years
but it seemed like a lot of the dialogue
in it or the conversations in it were
just kind of like prattling for the sake
of it like for example there's a scene
where ian
goes over to like it's halloween night
and he goes over to um
michelle's house like where she lives
with her aunt and uncle and he goes over
there and takes halloween candy and
they're all like giving out the kids
trick-or-treat like i said it's very
very wholesome
and they're giving out uh candy and
everything and then there's this kind of
this long it's not long but it's just
like you know several paragraphs of
conversation about the aunt and uncle
like teasing michelle about oh she
should have been a great artist and
stuff and like getting this big box out
like all and showing ian like all these
paintings that she done like going back
to third grade and it's just i was like
that's nice and everything but that
doesn't really like play into the larger
story like thematically or anything like
that it was just seemed like it was in
there for the sake of being in there
like you know and that's what i'm saying
so that's what i'm saying about a lot of
the conversations being
not really like
you know kind of not really being uh
relevant to like the larger narrative or
the themes of the story or anything like
that and i will say too that the scenes
in the middle part of the book get a
little bit repetitive i feel like
because like ian has another
dream about like seeing burn ghosts or
seeing like the
you know the um the floors or whatever
the ceiling collapsing
and fire and stuff and then michelle
sees the creepy nun a few times and has
some dreams that are they're not the
same but
you know they're similar enough that i
kind of wish that it had been more like
a progression of
you know what's that little
you know thing and it's kind of like
that because you know at the beginning
it's like oh we see like a couple faces
in the window but i feel like because
the book started out with
the old guy seeing
burned like charred people like in the
backseat of his car and he crashed and
then you start right out with ian having
a nightmare
about the school burning down and about
seeing these charred figures so it's
kind of like you're it just kind of like
seemed like it blew its wad like right
at the beginning like that's what the
main bulk of the thing and you know so
the story as it goes along it's just
episodic it's just like more of that and
but it's slightly getting like worse and
worse i guess as the time goes on
because later on they do have like other
things have to do with their own death
and stuff like that
but i do kind of feel like i even though
i did like that beginning like with
because it was really it really sucked
you in with this horrific imagery but
then after that it seemed like it didn't
really have any place to go so it seems
like more episodic than kind of like a
natural progression that's the only
thing about that so you know i i just
did kind of wish that it was
as i said more of a progression than uh
than repeated episodes of one or more of
the characters seeing
essentially variations on the same thing
or the same manifestations the same
apparitions or whatever but as i said uh
all in all this is a pretty entertaining
kind of cursed school type of story uh
has a really good like spooky autumn and
winter setting which i'm really into uh
again a lot of the visuals the way
they're described like the way that the
charred people and all that kind of
stuff are actually really really good
and like really really spooky would
actually make a good movie because i
could kind of like see it in my head so
i thought that was kind of cool as far
as that goes it's like i kind of feel
like maybe the characterization the
dialogue could have been a little bit
better
and some stuff probably could have been
trimmed out like some of the dialogue
could have been trimmed out or tightened
up some or
you know more in service of like the
main story but overall i thought this
was like a pretty good time and i read
it pretty quickly and um if you're just
looking for something that's kind of
like a simple straightforward
uh kind of old-fashioned ghost story
this would be a good thing to read
around halloween it has you know some of
it takes place on halloween as i said it
starts in september or august and
september and then just goes up until
like right before christmas break so
it's a very fall and winter type story
like in new england and so it does have
that sort of vibe to it which i really
like so if you're looking for something
like that to put you in that kind of
mood whether it's around halloween or
not
then it's definitely good for that it's
not a super complicated story you know
it doesn't have like a million subplots
or anything like that it's very very
straightforward doesn't have a lot of
plot twists or anything like that but if
that's all you're looking for just kind
of like an old-fashioned sort of ghost
story like i said this almost kind of
gave me
the vibe of like the lady in white that
that movie but even though that's kind
of like more of a murder mystery but
it's like a ghost story too
and that kind of had a lot more plot
tendrils this one is just pretty
straightforward but as i said it was a
good time overall so i'd recommend it if
you're into that kind of thing so that
will do it for this tomes of terror i
will see you guys on the next one bye